So this is a residential area of a
suburban town in Massachusetts.
And if you look on my right, you will
actually see that there are nicely
paved sidewalks.
But we know from what we just talked
about for the built environment and
walkability, access and availability of
sidewalks isn't the only thing that
determines walkability.
Other factors that influence walkability
include mixed land use and
proximity to common destinations, such
as grocery stores and banks.
And so for here, while there are
sidewalks available, it is primarily
residential, and so there are no other
places that you can get to via
walking, in terms of common
destinations.
So thinking back to what we talked about
in terms of street connectivity,
I'm about to pull into a
cul-de-sac, which is
essentially a dead end street.
Again, there are sidewalks available,
but you'll see that very few people
are actually walking around.
And there's only one main road in order
to get from various houses to
other places.
So it would be a lot faster to drive to
one house on this particular loop
than walking from one
house to another.
So here, you see, is where
the loop occurs, and it's
essentially a dead end road.
All right.
And now we're headed back
to the main road.
So here we are headed into a large
shopping center, and this is actually
pretty typical of a lot of places in
the United States, particularly in
suburban or rural areas.
There are lots of different restaurants
and stores around,
including grocery stores,
banks, clothing stores.
You can see that the parking lots are
actually incredibly expansive.
So the stores line the perimeter, but
in terms of the parking spaces
available, there's no shortage
of parking around here.
And even though all of the different
stores are pretty walkable--
you can walk from, for example, the
grocery store to a pet store or a
sandwich stop across the street--
nobody is walking around.
Everybody is driving.
So somewhere in the shopping center are
all the people who came in these
cars, but we actually don't see
them at all, except going to
and from their cars.
In this area, you'll see that the street
planning and urban design is
actually much more friendly to walkers
and bikers than it is for drivers, as
evidenced by the multiple crosswalks
and the ample sidewalk space for
pedestrians and for bikers.
So when we think about walkability, we
usually think about how conducive an
area is to walking.
But biking is another way in which we
can be physically active and still get
from place to place.
On the left here, we have some Hubway
bikes, which you can rent for about $6
for a 24-hour period.
Behind me, you can see that there's
mixed land use, a mix of commercial
shops for the most part.
But there are also apartment buildings
that are located behind the shops.
So this is an area where you can see
that there's a good quality of land
mixed use, both residential
and commercial.
Welcome back.
I hope you enjoyed the tour.
You've seen different characteristics of
the built environment and the food
environment in different
areas in Massachusetts.
But you might also be wondering, what
are some of the other characteristics
of neighborhoods around the
US and around the world.
For this online activity, you can
explore two different websites to get
a sense of how different neighborhoods
are within the US, as
well as in other countries.
The first website is walkscore.com.
Walkscore.com provides an index of
walkability, ranging from 0 to 100,
100 being the highest.
They provide this information using
online and iOS services.
The second website that you can visit
is the US Department of Agriculture
Food Environment Atlas.
This particular website provides a map
of the US, and although you can't
enter in addresses, you can click on
different areas on the map to get a
sense about differences between
neighborhoods in access and proximity
of grocery stores.
The USDA Food Environment Atlas also
provides information about food
deserts in particular areas
in the United States.